every time I seen you fight you climb in
there alone
every time you bled you bled your blood
when you sat down on that stool and it
felt like death and you thought you
couldn't get up but you got up you did
that you need to get back to that um
actually Aaron I think you're so great
and but I'm a writer I'm your writer
here my subject and from now on we need
to just keep it professional
you know yeah I think we really like
each other and once you start dating
what I know what I might oh god huh
stuck I'm not gonna
pac-man's faster than I remember
Pacman's always been faster than the
ghosts we're gonna happen
they weren't kidding
the safe is serious how serious we
talking Scottie it's a Carbondale
it's from 1910 nature the same steel is
the Titanic Wow can you crack it
well here's the thing it doesn't do so
well in the cold
none were that iceberg did ya man had
killed DiCaprio
killed everybody need not kill the old
lady she's still throw the jewel into
the ocean